League of Legends is a game where the
meta is constantly changing every patch
is different with certain characters and
strategies being deemed the right pick
but there are always bad ideas first
pick Teemo all ad no jungler there are
strats that just shouldn't work but
sometimes these insane
idiotic ideas are actually genius today
we wanted to celebrate the craziest
picks plays and strategies in League of
Legends here are the top 10 insane
League strats that actually worked
kicking off our list at the number 10
spot is a moment that left everyone
watching LCS wondering if they'd
accidentally tuned into a solo queue
game instead during the 2014 spring LCS
cloud 9 were a force to be reckoned with
they were so good that their middling or
hai figured he could afford to troll TSM
in the very first game of the regular
season really mentality for balls is
something that always keeps in the game
we put about any champion
listen no no welcome to the North
American LC yes that's right he picked
Teemo Teemo is the bane of soloqueue but
at a high level he's just not that good
at least that's what everyone thought
turns out that hi knew something that
everyone else didn't Teemo was broken on
that patch he's gonna keep him there for
the fight he is almost locking down five
members they don't want to move they're
all magnetically attracted to him and
dyrus is too focused for cloud nine
right now this could give wildturtle the
rest of the team enough time to do
damage but cloud 9 is just to take I
actually flashed in from behind the
fight here to just pop Ohio turtle as he
was trying to do this fight and once
that happened the fight was over
bjergsen got distracted finishing off
since there's no e to carry there's no
dammit play high-handed burek sin the
single most embarrassing loss in league
history coming in at number 9 might be a
recent strat but it made history while
the LPL was on break due to Kovan
nineteen world champion top laner the
shy decided to experiment in the top
lane and he stumbled across one of the
weirdest picks you'll ever see this is
going to leave I was gonna say
misfortune oh yes yes yes this is the
thing Calista is an ad carry she's not
just designed for the bot lane her kit
is built around having a support in the
lane with her but the shy defied
convention and he played her in the top
lane solo the thing about Beach is that
they need to recognize how much of a
problem the shy current rolled down he
doesn't that's a problem he doesn't care
chieftain he's got a limp away but guess
what the shiz teleported top lane he
don't kill her about this damn teamfight
he cares about pushing non-stop here
they show him to peak performance here
on patch 10.4 with Calista top there are
some technical reasons why this worked
out for him but the fact of the matter
is that until that moment no one ever
took Calista top in all six years of her
being in the game and
one would have called it a troll pick
but the shy annihilated his opponent
number eight on our list shows why
creative players will always have the
upper hand the support just makes so
much sense
usually Leona is an aggressive support
that delivers pressure in lane while
allowing her ADC to snag final blows but
during Game three of the quarterfinals
at Worlds 2017 misfits decided to defy
expectations and build a slightly more
menacing Leona
[Applause]
pull the trigger by using the fervor of
battle mastery which is meant for damage
dealers not supports every single one of
Leona's attacks made the next one even
stronger
shield and now the assists are going
across the map with this added damage
and Leona's natural tankiness ignore
sliced through SKT and lead misfits to
victory by slaughtering the three-time
world champions bot lane I mean who
accounts for an eighth stack fervor
Leona in a hit a level one all enemy
it's insane at our number seven spot we
have kick asses insane Twisted Fate
jungle pick hold on wait a minute
alright so we got a lock and Leblanc
just jungle to you Langston already
alright the TF is going for the early
gank he went crazy with the jungle
Twisted Fate during the semi-finals of
IEM San Jose uol upset TSM the NA Titans
on home soil how well they had kickers
and Twisted Fate in the jungle can they
get here once again into the pipeline
he's only lost boy left alive he'll be
closed down power of evil should be able
to finish this one up and then it is
traditionally a mid laner Twisted Fate
seemed like a crazy pick for the jungle
but Kiki's made it work and managed to
sneak up on his opponent's ganking and
stunning them with ease leaving TSM in
disarray wow really well done that to
bay in Santorini is a stunning car comes
down to the hook as well also
and ultimate coming out and it is power
of evil yes the kill in the end the only
way you stop a team from seating at this
point is if you fight them but in those
two men going down instantly Kiki's
gonna go to the back as well they finish
opiates and and that is the eighth and
this is gonna be game number one of the
semi-final here the Intel Extreme
Masters San Jose going to the Unicorn
number 6 on our list reminds us why
Capps is the king of bizarre and
outlandish mid lane champions made the
statement before that caps can play
everything I did not expect a mid lane
Fame to be a thing that's crazy
it's the 2018 EU LCS semi finals fnatic
vs. misfits game 3 and both teams are
tied there was a lot of pressure on
Capps but for reasons no one could
explain
he picked Vayne first time we have ever
seen a vein made in the EU LCS and Capps
the all-pro mid laner is the ones who
bring it out Vayne is an ad carry in
case you didn't know not a mid laner
she's squishy and any traditional mid
laner should dunk on her
so naturally his own team was confused
[Music]
serious is it's gonna win us two game
applause
[Music]
[Music]
at number five we have an unusual but
straight-up broken double support strat
Sona and Tarek sounds like a useless
botlane duo but it turns out that never
dying and having stuns for days is
actually pretty good but now he his
stopwatch gonna be doing some work Muniz
getting away butch gaming under pressure
they lose to Jensen get the damage
originally made popular by TSM Academy
other teams quickly began adopting the
strat most notably Team Liquid who used
Sona and Tarek to devastate clutch
gaming in Game five of the 2019 LCS
summer semi-finals Sona tahm Kench has
been winning Lane this is the tilter
make him play something he is miserable
playing oh me is that how you win by
clutch gaming but Team Liquid show why
they're the best diamond
and look the strat seems dumb but what's
even dumber is how boring it was to
watch and play thank god riot got rid of
his [ __ ]
League of Legends isn't a game about one
player carrying everyone but our number
four entry is a strap that enables just
that the gold funnel strat was all about
a team making sure one player got all
the gold possible with their teammates
usually giving up their own to keep the
carry fed everyone got in on this
because once you hit a certain point in
the game that carry led you to a free
win but one match in particular should
show you just how crazy gold funneling
got Griffin versus SKT during the lck
Summer 2018 regular season Griffin able
to clean up is going to be able to get
away with a but wolf goes blank
on the run here the leave is coming in
the fight for still in the backline
doing that them it's targeting low here
is going to be able to knock him down
but it's not enough fight for still free
hitting and that should be in the rest
of SKT looking to go down here bang will
not survive and that will be your ace as
Griffin cleanup it was hard to choose
just one of Zhi Zhu's insane off meta
pics from 2019 but we figured that their
bizarre comp against SKT and MSI that
year should make a pretty good number
three on our list it was a high-stakes
match 2 to 2 with the winner moving on
to the grand finals but for some reason
g2 were still clowning on their
opponents with insane champion picks as
the pike cover coming out from
200 and we have no idea where the pike
is going it could be made it could be
talked you want to continue that
flexibility this syndrome could be
bought Blaine I think what syndra's in
the vault lane I genuinely believe that
that Sentra is in the bot lanes to put
pike who is normally a support when top
syndra normally a mid laner went bought
and sure that sounds stupid but those
were comfort picks for wonder and perks
and they dumpster
[Applause]
[Music]
taking the runner-up spot on this list
is the time that the rocks tigers
drafted misfortune as brace yourself a
support that's the pushing lanes they
actually have done an insta left miss
force are then really weird I don't care
about my last point this is an insta
locked misfortune supportive F at the
2016 world semi finals vs. SKT Rox
Tigers had one goal to counter the
incredibly powerful Zyra support at that
time to do this the team devised a
brilliant plan of drafting misfortune
and ash in the bot lane aggressive you
outraged it now on paper pairing 280
sees together is pretty wack but it
turns out misfortune is really good in
two Zyra and even better with an ash by
her side also worth noting is sort of
sort of par for the course
did it level four
here's the jump in a few more attacks
we'll do it and that's first
in fact it worked so well they ended up
winning games two and three before SKT
were forced to waste a ban on this crazy
misfortune pic before that moment
misfortune was basically irrelevant but
the Rox Tigers brought her back and
their support strat lives on to this day
MF is picked up that's that classic
counter to Zara that emerged last year
at Worlds with the Rox Tigers using it
six updates beyond barren and the red
speck at our number one spot is the
single ballsiest strat in league of
legends history fakers LeBlanc is
legendary in 2015 he was undefeated on
the champion and most teams just banded
so they could avoid dealing with it but
EDG decided to face the demon king
head-on Baker has never lost with
LeBlanc on the competitive stage well
and OH
EDG left LeBlanc open and baited faker
into picking it then drafted a comp
exclusively designed to [ __ ] with him
there roaming kill strategy is really
strong and what a move by Mako used a
minion that soul shackles faker there's
going to be clearlove coming up as well
faker gets the mimic there and he's
going to be able to get out alive they
are still following with a bit of on the
hunt pressure righteous glory just wears
off and they go in Kouros right the
middle with vengeful Maelstrom on that's
a huge damage the soul shackle causing
SKT to flash out every which way
EDG is all over as gates
over the health bars and they drop
everyone but thank you and finger elixir
of sorcery on him as well to get out a
bit of extra damage Goro finds them with
the twisted advances he posed to
Distortion and he can't get out alive
Lawrence Forrester turned as soon as he
nars out unfortunate for SKT it
shouldn't have worked in fact in any
other situation this comp was a terrible
idea but faker crumbled this is another
very dangerous bear and EDG needs it to
win here comes SK Telecom banky not
there for the 50/50 baron going very low
at 1,500 it is going to go over to
clinical faker they take down banker
immediately SK Telecom t1 are wiped the
Nexus turrets are going down LPL's
Edward gaming are the 2015 midseason
Invitational champions
[Applause]
all right folks that's our list do you
think we were insane and missed any
strats or did our list actually work be
sure to let us know in the comments sub
to the channel and remember always pick
team Oh your team will thank you for it
yeah I know this is my life now I am I'm
a score eSports resident League of
Legends experts as as the as the
resident expert it makes me really
excited to kind of flex my knowledge you
know about this truly terrible eSport
valor --nt has killed it it was dying
before valor and came out but now it's
like dead like now it's like straight-up
dead nobody watches or plays League of
Legends any more years League of Legends
dead long live Valerie